sound the drums of War wordsmiths
because today I teach you about
rebellion
man I'm a great influence
it's a noun it means war or pushback
against a government or an authority
right the American Revolutionary War
began as a rebellion against the British
crown now this word has Latin origins
The Root bell comes from the Latin
Bellum meaning War
and the prefix re means again against or
back so Rebels stand up and maybe go to
war against something right they're
they're seeking change so two countries
going to war with each other is not a
rebellion but an uprising within a
country protesting a tyrannical ruler
that's a rebellion so re and Bell those
are our word Parts I want to focus on
today I'm going to put on some music for
about 10 seconds and while I do that
come up with as many words as you can
that contain those elements
okay
let's go
[Music]
okay here are three that I came up with
uh remake like there's an old movie and
you're making a new version of it right
you're making it again remake
belligerent one of my favorite
adjectives it means hostile or warlike a
belligerent person starts a lot of
arguments a lot of fights and this last
one Rebel right also contained within
Rebellion this word can be a noun or a
verb I wanted to flag it because
pronunciations are different depending
on how you use it when it's a person
they're a rebel but the thing that a
rebel does is Rebel fights back right
the emphasis changes from the first
syllable to the second right
first syllable second syllable the nouns
verbed the rebels rebelled in their
Rebellion let's use rebellion in a
sentence or two to the mind of a
dictator something as innocent as a
sidewalk chalk drawing could be seen as
an act of rebellion so it's seen as an
act of War right and or of open
resistance to the dictator look at a
mouth open he looks so scandalized by
Little House Marta rebelled quietly she
pulled doors marked push she rode her
bike through the drive-through she
microwaved fish in the office I feel
like contributing to kind of an
anti-fish narrative here and that's
unfair I microwave fish in the Khan
Academy lunchroom whatever I'm not too
proud to admit it does that make me a
hero Maybe
does it make me a rebel oh you betcha
now if you'll excuse me your boy's got a
serving of tuna casserole in the
refrigerator and I can't eat it cold
if you know what I mean so you can learn
anything damn it out